let's talk about the pittsburgh steelers
a team
that has clinched its division title it
would have clinched whether they won or
lost on sunday against the colts because
when the browns lost that gave it to the
steelers
they will be resting key starters at a
minimum we know about quarterback ben
roethlisberger
there may be others let's hear from mike
tomlin talking about
going to face their archrival cleveland
browns
with at a minimum ben roethlisberger not
playing
one by available in this uh in this
single elimination tournament
um you know we're not going to be that
team we made that bid so we're prepared
to lay in it
that's the most significant variable for
us and so that being
said uh given an opportunity to airmail
a player or two to the postseason
we will uh ben will not be playing this
week
we'll turn toward mason rudolph in our
young quarterback positional group
and give those guys an opportunity um
we'll look
potentially uh arresting some other guys
in terms of making them inactive but the
number of those guys and who those guys
are
will be determined as we push through
the week make no mistake about it
um it does not change our intentions in
terms of going to cleveland this weekend
football is our game our job is winning
we intend to do our job
we intend to prepare with that mindset
and ultimately let our play lead us to
that destination
um we're not seeking comfort we're not
grading ourselves on the curve
uh this game is on the schedule and so
the guys will be on the field will
represent
us in the standard that is the
pittsburgh steelers will be the standard
i have a hard time reconciling the back
end of what he said with the front end
don't tell me that you're going to play
to win if you're not putting your best
players on the field there's a strategic
reason
for you not to put your best players on
the field and i understand that you're
not going to tell those guys to go out
there
and lay down but if you're truly trying
to win the game
you're using your best player so tough
needle
for mike tomlin to thread there chris
yeah well he's trying to keep you know
the pedal to the metal a little bit
about the urgency in the building and
we're still trying to
you know big picture win something here
and it doesn't mean that we just like
take the week off from practice and do
anything like that
you know i don't but you're right it's
hard to sell that to your team totally
but
as you know in the nfl guys get their
opportunity they don't know any
anything different than let's go 100 and
try to win that game
now it is going to be backups like you
said but i can't
i mean i don't know mike what do you
think here with pittsburgh for with me
for the pittsburgh steelers for this
team
what what they've had to endure this
year it makes sense yes sit big ben
all the way i would say sit you know i
said on monday i thought
maybe the offense comes out and does
something there okay that's fine the
defense is what i'm concerned about they
i want them to sit
they're the team they're the unit on the
steelers
that needs to be really special come
play off time
and help out an offense that we're not
sure so sure is
really consistently good right now so i
understand that
and you know i know you and i have
talked before too
it's a steelers team that's been through
a lot and their front seven on defense
plays the whole damn
game they gotta be exhausted they gotta
need
you know a little time off here i would
do that
mentally mentally and physically because
they never had a bye week
this year week four became their buy
unexpectedly they were preparing to face
the titans that week so they practiced
as if they were going to play
that game didn't happen it got moved to
week seven which was their actual bye
week so
bye bye to the bye week and then when
thanksgiving rolls around and you think
you're going to get a mini buy
on the back end of the thanksgiving
night game against the ravens
that goes bye-bye as well because six
days later they finally played the
ravens so they've constantly been
in football mode they've constantly been
in preparing for the next game mode
even when the next game doesn't happen
so there's a mental aspect to it that i
think is important
with ben there's an injury aspect even
though when you look at the last three
weeks of the injury reports there's
nothing on there by way of injury and i
don't know what's true and what's
not true but obviously he could use
a game where he's not in uniform and
that was one of the keys to me
for tomlin he was talking about other
guys that may be inactive that tells me
that rothersburger won't even be dressed
right
in a uniform he'll he will have clothes
on on the sideline
but the idea that tj what do you
do you put him in a uniform and tell him
just stay there
on the sideline you almost have to keep
some of those guys
out of pads and no helmet in sight
to keep them off of the field and you
can't just kind of
partially have them there
it's all or it's nothing for a lot of
those guys which makes them great so
there's only so many guys on the roster
who can be inactive it makes you wonder
how many of those defensive starters
will end up right not in uniform and the
ones who are in uniform are they going
to be happy standing around in uniform
for three hours in cleveland
no you know probably not especially if
they're not gonna play but that's just
what they're gonna have to deal with i'm
sure there's gonna be a certain amount
of players that
yeah they dress up they go through
warm-ups they play maybe the first two
three series of the game they might be
out you know yeah then you're just
sitting there with a jacket on and
yeah you're jealous of the guys who were
in street clothes certainly
but man when it comes to like you know
cam
hayward tj watt stefan tuitt
alua lou on the on the front
i mean those guys i'm resting them and
if they are playing
it's very limited snaps maybe just to
get out there get
going for a little bit and then get them
out of the football game i'd be too
worried
of something happening and like you've
pointed out with the coven 19
everything like that the mental physical
gymnastics they've had to go through
i feel like they've been a little bit of
a worn out football team they need a
little recharge
is it enough though for the steelers to
kind of
throw the hay in the barn and slam the
door and say well open it up again
wild card round based on one half of
good football
is that one half now it triggered
euphoria in the locker room with the
t-shirts and the hats we talked about
that the other day
of course at least i'm wearing green
today if they decide to put the grinch
back up but it's it's a it's a real
thing they didn't
demonstrate conclusively and
convincingly that they
fixed their problems they just woke up
for less than a half of football is that
enough
for them to confidently say we'll be
ready to go when the wild card rolls
around
i don't you know i they're going to tell
themselves yes
that yeah but i don't know if i'm sold
on that that's why a monday show i
we talked about it i came out i said i
don't know this might be one of those
things where
maybe you do come out and play week 17
just to get out there and kind of
capitalize on the momentum a little bit
one more you know one more you know
opportunity to go okay we are back we
feel good let's go
all right we're ready for the playoffs
but i feel like you know they came to
the conclusion that the risk
was not worth the reward at that point
and that
they saw enough and big ben's health and
feeling
a hundred percent for the wild card game
is is more important than
you know the things we're mentioning and
i'll say this to mike because
for my podcast today i'm going back a
little bit
and watching the matchups of these
playoff game implications right
and i watched the browns brown steelers
game
from from week six i believe it was
there you you could tell
big ben from watching that after
watching what i saw last weekend
is not moving the same there's
definitely a lower leg issue there's no
doubt about that
the last few games how he stands in the
pocket just
flat footed as can be doesn't move at
all
not that he's been moving a ton this
year but when i turned that game on i
went
oh wait he is moving a little bit within
the pocket here
and definitely more than he has the last
few weeks so you know i think there is
something there and something to keep an
eye on
and i doubt that a week off is going to
make him anything better it's just a
question of avoiding making it
worse there have been reports of serious
concerns about the knees
a hyper-extended knee suffered in week
13 but again it was after week 13
where he disappears from the injury
report except for his perfunctory
wednesday off that
is not injury related and there's no
mention of knee week 14
15 16 or presumably week 17 we'll see
because the days the day that we get our
first look at the injury
reports for all of the games on sunday
because all of the games this week are
on sunday we'll get all the injury
reports today and we'll see who's
healthy and who's not healthy
and whether or not big ben lands on that
injury report
now the steelers could be strategically
and deliberately conceding the three
seed and versus the two seed they take
the three
they give the two to the buffalo bills
it doesn't mean as much this year
remember what tj watt told me on sunday
they still have a hard
time creating energy they have to they
have to
create it from within in that empty
stadium so does it really
matter if you're playing the bills in
the division around if that's how it
shakes out if both teams win
in the wild card round and steelers it
bills versus bills at steelers does it
really matter whether they're hosting
that game
or going to buffalo now you don't want
to travel if you don't have to but
chris if the bills are able to have 6
700 fans present that plan has been
submitted
a decision on whether or not they can
have fans present for the playoff games
is
imminent that's still energy even if
it's negative energy you've talked about
how
visiting players feed off of the hatred
that they feel coming from
it's still something to get you going i
don't know maybe from the steelers
perspective they looked at it and said
for what we gain by potentially being
the two seed it's not worth what we
potentially lose
by declining to give some of our key
players a break heading into a post
season
i think that's fair i think that's
exactly what it is mike if you made me
guess you're right i mean it's just
again it's the other it's another risk
reward factor that they're not willing
to
gamble with that risk and the reward
isn't in a year like this
that big of a deal to be at home as the
two seed
you know if it does play out the way
where okay
buffalo you know uh somehow
well it will play out that way either
way but yes i don't think it's a big
deal
the only thing that's different all
right at all
is hey there is an advantage to playing
at home and being home
there's no doubt about that is it some
huge advantage no
but if you gave me a choice as a
football player in my prime right now to
go back and play whatever it is
if you could tell me i could play a home
game or an away game i'm going to pick a
home game
yes i'd like to you know be in the
environment that i'm comfortable in
uh and there is something to that but
not such a great advantage to where
you're gonna go
well we're gonna play a week 17 and
we're a banged-up football team but
we're still gonna play
you know just to get the two seed in a
year where
you know like you said it's not a ton of
fans and it's not a big difference
well especially if you're going to
undermine your ability to get to the
division around where you would be
hosting the three seed versus going on
the road is the three seed
if you can't get there because your team
is too beat up
exactly as the baltimore ravens for
example come to town if you get the two
seed
see there's so many moving parts as to
who's gonna be in what seed in the afc
yeah that it's hard to deliberately
avoid someone because you really don't
know there's still a roll of the dice
you may wake up monday morning hey we're
the three seed we've avoided the ravens
oh crap they're the sixth seed and
uh now we got we still have to play them
i i think at some level
even though they would never admit it
that's a game that the steelers would
love to avoid if they can
well i i listen this is where i was
gonna go because i know we're going to
talk about you know
sean mcdermott and the bills here in a
second but we might as well just include
it in this conversation
i'm dead serious with this like if i'm
the buffalo bills
i i'm doing anything i can i'm
scoreboard watching this weekend i'm
doing anything i can not to have to play
the baltimore ravens
that would be my the baltimore ravens to
me if you're the buffalo bills that's
like the worst team they could see
i wouldn't want to deal with them i i
would i would i think to a degree
try to avoid them the best i can like
like you said
there's no guarantee of anything you
know
we don't know how this is gonna play out
i don't know like
how it could all play out to where where
baltimore can jump around between
the five six and seven seed i mean it
doesn't look like
you know i don't know so you're right
you don't know how to play that but i do
think that would be a scary matchup for
yes the steelers even the buffalo bills
man you got to play them that running
right running
you know offense with lamar jackson and
of course that's secondary even if
you're
josh allen and all them that's a little
daunting and i i
that would cross my mind if i'm
mcdermott this week preparing for this
one
and a lot of those pieces are going to
be unfolding at the same time the early
games include
steelers at browns ravens at bengals
and dolphins at bills the 425
window has the colts hosting the jaguars
and the titans at the texans so
the picture is going to be incomplete
right in the one o'clock window
you need an analytics expert just to
help you understand
so what where are you going are you the
two seat are you two-seater
who are you likely to face three seed
who are you likely to face and it could
be that the bills are trying to concede
the two seed the steelers are trying to
concede
the two seed if the steelers lose the
two seed is buffalo's win or lose
against the miami dolphins and sean
mcdermott has said they're going to keep
their plans
internal for what they do on sunday i
believe that
given everything the bills have
accomplished
the past five weeks yeah and micah hyde
said yesterday the hail mary
play sparked them and they had that week
off they had to stew on it
for 14 days before they played again
they've won by double digits
minimum every week since then they've
won
86 to 28 combined score their last two
games
i would keep riding it i would keep
letting it flop
i i would keep and especially if you
can avoid having to face a division
rival in the postseason
you don't want to mess with the dolphins
in the postseason
it's been a long time since they've
played them the dolphins are a lot
better than they were when the dolphins
gave the bills a pretty good game back
in week two 27-17 i think was the final
score although i could be wrong i'll
just act like i'm right
you know what the hell uh i think it was
27 to 17 though but but
uh you don't want to see them again in
the wild card round you don't want that
you don't want to see them again at all
you would rather
although i know you think the ravens are
a bad matchup i just think there's
something
psychological about a division rival
coming
into your building in the playoffs that
you'd like to avoid it if you can
and i just think that they need to
continue to ride this wave
that shows everyone that they're for
real they need to convince themselves
they're for real
and convince everyone else there for
real as they head into the playoffs so
they're not one and done again i think
that's so much of why we've seen what
we've seen recently
they are desperate to show everyone and
themselves
they're not a team that just punches a
ticket to the playoffs and then punches
out
no i mean i i think you're right and i
think you're right they're a young team
they're just capitalizing on momentum
and being a consistent football team and
being one of the better
best teams in football and in that
conversation i'm with you
if i'm buffalo i'm riding the momentum
i'm not letting us have a week off right
now
you know again the late they had a late
bye week this year
they should be a fairly fresh football
team you know they had a lot of guys get
healthy really in the last six or seven
weeks too to where
you know they didn't have to deal with
the wear and tear of the early part of
the season
so i would think they're somewhat of a
fresh football team
and yeah i wouldn't want to let my foot
off the gas pedal i really feel like
hey more times than not the great teams
the great playoff teams we've seen in
history whether that's the team that's
had to
you know fight their way into the
playoffs and have been playing
playoff games all through december or
that number one or two seed that we've
seen in the past
who's had a play through december to
make sure they're a number one or two
seed
those always seem to be the teams that
capitalize playoff time
that always so that would scare me and
the other thing i would throw into this
little thing here is you know i'd want
to beat
i'd want to play capitalize on the
momentum like you said
keep that going i'd want to beat the
dolphins one more time
and then within beating the dolphins you
know i think there
again you'll increase your chances to
where
we expect baltimore to beat cincinnati
baltimore will be a higher seed
you'll be a higher seed because you win
and you avoid them i'd be more worried
again
about baltimore than i am miami you tell
me wait you have a chance
to have tua and the miami dolphins
coming to town
or lamar jackson and the baltimore
ravens
i'm sorry i love the dolphins and what
brian flores is doing but i'm going to
pick them all day long i'm going to go
i'll take two in the dolphins sorry i
don't want to deal with that other team
and that might be their best way this is
like what you're saying just pedal to
the metal and go
by the way the score in week two was
31-28
dolphins losing to the bills i was
misfiling in my brain the week one score
between the bills and the jets 27-17 so
right church
wrong pew uh for that 27-17 score thank
you pete for clearing that up for me
here's another reason to knock out the
dolphins
whatever it is that they're cooking up
that feels special
yeah especially after the game last
saturday night
with the raiders and the the the twisted
head and the
the throw and the win and you know if
you can knock them out of the playoffs
you kind of not not that you're going to
completely kill it but you at least
slow down this this growth of something
with the dolphins that may be getting
out of control and now next year you've
got a real issue with the dolphins in
your division
if you can spray cold water all over
this thing that they're
putting together maybe it helps you next
year too
if they get to the playoffs maybe they
have a hell of a lot more confidence
next year and they're more of a problem
for you next year so there's an added
benefit
to delivering an uppercut that knocks
them out of the playoffs chris and as
you said if it means the ravens have a
higher spot
and you don't see them right out of the
gates all the more reason
to take advantage of the opportunity to
beat the dolphin then
look let's just simplify it your team is
playing extremely well
keep playing extremely well keep doing
what you're doing
we here you know the cliches we hear
from coaches all the time
don't reside in your fears is one that i
think makes a ton of sense
especially this week because we've seen
teams time and again
most recently the ravens last year when
they took their foot off the gas
they rested guys week 17 then they have
a bye exactly that's three weeks between
games and then income the titans who
just beat the patriots
they catch you flat-footed and the next
thing you know you're
done exactly i think you want to keep
going and
and you want and now you need to be
ready to stand up
and answer the tough questions if josh
allen or someone else get injured in a
meaningless game
you need to be willing to say look we've
seen time and again what happens to
teams
that deliberately surrender their
momentum right and we were not going to
deliberately surrender our momentum yeah
no
you're right you're going to have to be
able to answer those questions certainly
but
we saw but that's the answer that's it
that i mean
act like they're afraid oh they're going
to go crazy if somebody gets injured
well they're going to be upset but you
say to them
we can't deliberately surrender our
momentum yeah we can't
you go through the fact what happens to
the teams that do right you can go
through the facts of time you just
mentioned it baltimore last year oh what
kansas city had to play week 17
last year oh they won guess what they
rode that momentum into the playoffs
went to the super bowl even though it
was
you know all over the place as far as
comeback wins and everything like that
you'll be able to point to if you're
sean mcdermott to go wait
tom brady and the new england patriots
went to
97 super bowls they played like week 17
every time
like every time didn't matter if they
had it locked up or a one seat or a two
seed they always played
they always kept the moment there is
something about just
playing staying in your routine staying
in game shape
staying battle tested all of those
things that's where it's
it's a tough balance for a coach here
you know mike tomlin i tell them to
arrest them
they're a different team they're beat up
it's been different they're a little
older in some spots okay they're
different the bills are a whole
different entity in themselves too
and they're not the steelers with this
you know a quarterback with you know
playoff history and all those things as
well
so i'm i'm with you mike all the way i
think you ride the
momentum and you know you comply the
percentages a little bit right
i mean you wrote yesterday okay
pittsburgh
looking good for cleveland right now
right and that football game
you know i don't know what happens with
buffalo and miami but i think we can
also
sit here and and just chalk it up and go
i feel pretty good that baltimore is
going to beat cincinnati
so there you have two of these four
teams we're talking about that are
really set up in a good spot to
where i mean it'd be shocking to me
if either one of those lose so you can
play it a little bit or figure it out a
little bit i guess is what i'm saying
i think you're right i think you're
right i mean if the browns lose to mason
rudolph
then they don't belong in the playoffs
if you if you
finish your season with the loss to the
jets and a loss to mason rudolph
you you don't deserve a specific table i
don't care how many wins you have oh we
got 10 wins we should be in not if you
can't beat the jets
and mason rudolph in back-to-back weeks
and of course the mason rudolph angle
means
a reunion with miles garrett that ugly
incident from last november when
garrett number one removed the helmet of
mason rudolph and then number two
whacked him over the head with it and
it's still amazing to this day that
rudolph didn't suffer a serious injury
that could be something
that that bubbles up during that game
especially if the browns are feeling
frustrated if the steelers are
are finding a way to beat the browns on
a day where the browns desperately need
to
win hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports